[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes dans une forêt primaire est
un gigantesque incendie se déclare en
l'espace de quelques heures les flammes
dévorent la flore faune retire la
broussaille les lianes se désagrège les
petites pousses tombe en sambre les
animaux fouisseurs se retrouvent piégés
dans leur terrier les autres fouilles y
prennent leurs pattes leur zèle leurs
écailles à leur cou tous sauf un seul
est inlassablement un petit colibri vol
frénétiquement jusqu'à l'art est bien la
plus proche et emprisonnent quelques
petites gouttelettes dans son tout petit
bec pour aller les déposer au dessus du
grand brasier et répète comme ça
d'exercice à l'infini tout à coup un
toucan à l'énorme bec l'interpellent et
lui dit mais mais tu es fou colibri est
ce que tu fais ne sert à rien le colibri
lui répond peut-être mais je fais ma
part vous connaissiez cette histoire
bon alors j'ai un peu triché en fait je
n'ai pas lu dans le bouquin c'est un
élément de décor mais si vous êtes
gentil je vous dirai à la fin de la
présentation le titre de ce livre qui
est assez à l'image de ce qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui
alors ça m'étonne pas que certains
connaissent cette histoire puisque ce
qui était à l'origine une légende
amérindienne a été très largement
utilisés diffuser ces trente dernières
années dans les milieux écologistes par
les grandes ong de défense de
l'environnement
mais elle a même été d'ailleurs à
l'origine j'y pense maintenant à la
création du mouvement colibris 1 2
cyrille djian et de pierre rabhi en 2007
mais ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui de
décortiquer avec vous si vous êtes
d'accord
vous êtes d'accord c'est pas tellement
l'histoire en elle-même mais plutôt
qu'un usage dont on s'en sert
aujourd'hui
depuis qu'elle est souvent récupérés par
des grands acteurs des milieux
politiques et économiques pour focaliser
l'écologie qu'on pourrait dire
mainstream autour des petits actes
individuels des écoles des éco gestes
comme on dit pardon sans jamais remettre
en question l'ensemble du système
économique devenue presque religieux
basé sur la croissance le productivisme
le consumérisme
alors d'abord j'aimerais si vous êtes
d'accord qu'on ne s'intéresse en fait
aux différents personnages de l'histoire
on pourrait commencer par le
protagoniste qui est donc le colibri qui
est le colibri et ben le colibri sais
vous vous qui avait décidé de ne plus
jamais acheter de produits emballés dans
du plastique qui allaient chercher vos
céréales vont tortellinis en vrac vous
qui fabriquer vous même votre shampoing
votre après rasage vous qui avez décidé
de lancer une activité de permaculture
ou d'agriculture urbaine qui fait
pousser des champignons dans du marc de
café sur votre balcon
vous êtes tous autant que vous êtes des
colibris le toucan qui est ici
représenté un peu comme le méchant dans
l'histoire mais moi en fait je trouve
qu'il n'est pas si méchant que ça c'est
simplement un animaux un animal pardon
de la forêt qui aussi peut-être
un moyen d'agir à petite échelle pour
lutter contre l'incendié il a juste un
plus gros becs que le colibri disons que
c'est peut-être votre ton temps robert
ou daniel dominique peu importe c'est
votre ton temps qui a qui a bien fait
carrière qui a bien gagné de la vie et
qui se moque parfois de vous quand ils
voient tous les efforts que vous faites
pour la planète qui pourrait vous dire
que effectivement face à la grande
déliquescence du monde c'est un peu vain
et du coup ci c'est plus vraiment le
tout quand le méchant parce que moi je
le trouve pas juste mais je le trouve
pas tellement méchant ce tout quand je
le trouve juste un petit peu finalement
pétrifié soit par un pessimisme tragique
là soit peut-être par une certaine
timidité douce et qu'il méchant parce
que toute une histoire toute histoire a
évidemment un méchant sinon c'est pas
une bonne histoire et du coup le méchant
et que je voudrais vous proposer dans
cette histoire est bien c'est le vautour
dont je n'ai rien personnellement contre
les boutons
d'ailleurs on pourrait faire une
parenthèse pour regretter aujourd'hui
collectivement que certains animaux
comme les chauves souris les requins les
layènes ont toujours eu terriblement
mauvaise presse dans notre culture
alors que ce sont des animaux essentiel
de la biodiversité donc j'espère que les
les ornithologues de la salle me
pardonneront cet excès de zèle
donc le vautour c'est celui qui se
trouve à l'orée du bois qui a participé
à allumer un incendie et qui
discrètement bad ces deux grands tels
pour entretenir les flammes tout en se
félicitant d'ailleurs que l'on se
focalise sur l'agitation du colibri
certes magnifiques est essentielle mais
vaine pour lutter contre un si grand
incendie
je voudrais prendre un premier exemple
avec pour le coup un acteur économique
vous connaissez sûrement cette célèbre
marque d'eau sucrée sombre pétillante
douce heureusement acidulées cette
boisson nous est vendu à raison de 4000
fois par seconde dans une bouteille en
plastique on en boirait entre 200 et 350
milliards de litres chaque année dans
les années 70
l'entreprise qui distribuait à l'origine
sa boisson dans des bouteilles en verre
consigné a décidé après avoir fait une
étude discrète presque secrète sur
l'impact environnemental des différents
contenants qui avait évidemment conclut
de façon tout à fait péremptoire que la
bouteille en verre consigné était la
solution écologique par excellence a
finalement passé a décidé de passer aux
plastiques jugée plus facile à produire
sans doute moins cher et plus pratique
pour le consommateur
aujourd'hui nous savons que ces
bouteilles en plastique sont recyclés
moins d'une fois sur deux et que de
toute façon on ne peut le faire qu'une à
deux fois maximum le reste comme dirait
le poète s'est brûlé ou enterrés mieux
encore ça termine dans nos océans qui
selon certains experts recèleront d'une
masse plus importante de plastique queue
de poisson à l'horizon 2050
mais ce qui est très amusant c'est que
l'entreprise en question organisé depuis
plusieurs années ce qu'on appelle
décline walk
vous connaissez les clean moult ce sont
des ballades où on ramasse les déchets
dans la rue ou sur la plage des balades
qui représente une part du colibri
certes cool et sympa très tendance
fashion à bord
mais surtout médiatique et symbolique
alors voilà un vrai vautours qui a
participé à allumer un incendie pour
l'occurrence le problème du plastique à
l'échelle mondiale qui encourage le
colibri ajouté ces petites gouttelettes
sur l'enfant dit pendant ce temps là il
continue d'entretenir les flammes
puisque nous avons appris l'année passée
grâce à un consortium de journalistes
européens que l'entreprise en question
avait demandé à son lobbyiste à
l'échelle européenne de baisser les
ambitions de l'europe sur la question de
recyclage des énergies renouvelables et
du retour à la consigne des exemples
comme celui ci dans le monde merveilleux
des affaires on en trouve treize à la
douzaine
mais le double discours du vautour
n'existe pas que niche et on va dire
chez les marchands de soda on le
retrouve aussi souvent perchés dans nos
institutions
ces derniers mois en belgique
force est de constater que l'offre
politique aura bien été obligés
d'adapter sa communication
face à la pression scientifique
académique et citoyennes ou qu'ils
affichent plus d'ambition climatique
plus d'ambition pour la protection la
préservation du système terre dans le
même temps on applaudit des deux ailes
en apprenant l'arrivée à liège d'un
géant chinois de lits commerce qui
représente absolument tout ce qui se
fait de pire en termes d'entrepreneuriat
durable avec une explosion du fret
aérien
alors que l'on sait aujourd'hui qu'il
s'agit d'un des moyens de locomotion les
plus énergivores et polluants la vente
de bibelots en plastique absolument
inutile confectionnés à un endroit de la
planète distribué à l'autre alors qu'il
faudrait tendre vers la sobriété la
création d'emplois directs certes mais
la destruction sur le long terme de
combien de petits commerces de proximité
qui fonctionne en circuit court comme ce
fut déjà le cas avec des milliers
d'épicerie de maraîchers de disquaires
de libraires de détail en électroménager
avec le triomphe de la grande
distribution et plus récemment de lits
commerce
alors moi c'est assez marrant parce que
du coup je parlais de la chine j'ai
envie de faire une petite réflexion
personnelle puisque ça fait deux ans que
je travaille dans l'écologie ont fait
avec mes amis des vidéos de
sensibilisation et de vulgarisation
autour des grands thèmes qui aujourd'hui
donne le rythme de la lutte contre la
destruction du vivant sur la terre et
donc j'aimerais vous parler de la chine
parce que ce qu'on entend souvent de la
part des toucans donc ceux qui sont pas
forcément très méchant mais qui se moque
un peu de nous quand même c'était très
bien ce que vous dites mais allez
d'abord dire ça aux chinois c'est
sûrement déjà entendu cette phrase
peut-être même déjà vous l'avez employés
allaient d'abord dire ça aux chinois et
cette phrase est très intéressante parce
que si tu il est vrai indéniable que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sur le
territoire de la chine ont littéralement
explosé ces trente dernières années qui
fabriquent nos téléphones portables qui
fabriquent nos nouvelles baskets notre
routine est électrique ne [ __ ] à
mouches électrique sur lequel on peut
griller les les colibris qui jusqu'à
l'année dernière
récupérer jusqu'à 85 % des déchets
plastiques produits en union européenne
lorsque les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre diminuent quelque part en
l'occurrence chez nous ça a été le cas
ces dernières années les émissions
territoriales de gaz à effet de serre
ont diminué sans qu'il y ait un
changement radical dans notre rapport
non seulement à la consommation mais
aussi à la production dans notre rapport
au monde bien il ya de fortes chances
pour qu'elle ait augmenté ailleurs fait
ce que d'aucuns appellent le syndrome
pitron du nom du journaliste l'a
théorisé la délocalisation de la
pollution si la chine est bien le
premier pays au monde en termes
d'émissions territoriale de gaz à effet
de serre elle est 42e en termes
d'émissions par habitant alors
j'aimerais revenir deux minutes à mon
histoire de colibri pour conclure
si j'aimerais que vous retenir une chose
de ma présentation ce soir j'ai
effectivement ce n'est pas tellement
cette histoire mais plutôt l'usagé qui
en est fait aujourd'hui pour que l'école
que l'écologie convergent avec cet
individualisme méthodologique de nos
sociétés est d'ailleurs à l'origine de
la plupart des comportements qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable
d'être à la hauteur en matière de climat
le prêt vert de préservation du vivant
et de protection de la planète terre on
ne fait pas de l'écologie en faisant de
l'écologie si les colibris ne peuvent
plus aujourd'hui se permettre de ne
faire que déposer quelques petites
gouttelettes au dessus du grand brasier
ils doivent aussi faire comme le merle
chanter lors que leur message soit
entendu et comme le pivert clic et les
vautours pour ne pas que l'humanité soit
le dindon de sa propre farce
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]